another thing that dr bright is not  allowed to do dr bright cannot give  scp-082 song requests  scp-082 loves to sing if there's  anything he loves more than lying and  feasting on human flesh it's busting out  a cheerful little tune from time to time  however as dr bright has shown that he  cannot be respectful of scp-082's tastes  or the comfort of those working around  him he is not permitted to request any  songs from  scp-082 ferdinand was recently reduced  to tears when his rendition of a classic  italian arya was interrupted by dr  bright's repeated cries of dew free bird  and he also expressed discomfort when dr  bright told him to perform like a virgin  he should know by now that fernan only  likes to sing one madonna song and it's  vogue